texas governor greg abbott calling for
an investigation
into the outages and he joins us now
live to explain
um i don't have a problem i'm going to
be very clear i'm an all the above guy
anything that works i'm all for
cheap energy i'm all for but that would
include
the lifeblood of the world's economy gas
uh
oil old-fashioned oil and coal uh
i'm not against nuclear energy either
i'm not against wind turbines but my
question is
if you have these rolling blackouts and
you got freezing weather
i mean uh and they're not reliable and
it's user to lose it
what good is it sean this shows how the
green new deal would be a deadly deal
for the united states of america
texas is blessed with multiple sources
of energy such as
natural gas and oil and nuke but you saw
from what trace said and that is our
wind in our solar
got shut down and they were collectively
more than 10
of our power grid and that thrust texas
into a situation where
it was lacking power in a state-wide
basis that was
power that was spread out by that ercot
organization or organization that you
were talking about as a result
it just shows that fossil fuel is
necessary
for the state of texas as well as other
states to make sure that we were
we'll be able to heat our homes in the
winter time and cool our homes in the
summertime
well and on the second level there i
mean i've interviewed
guys working on the keystone xl pipeline
and i know like
you know you have leonardo dicaprio and
scarlett johansson and hollywood say
well let's close the dakota pipeline now
they're going to close
down anwar uh well that
these are high paying career jobs at a
point in the middle of a pandemic one
and
in the middle of a time when uh illegal
immigrants are going to be made legal
which is going to drive wages down
these are high paying career jobs for
people
so the question is is that the same
problem california's been facing with
these rolling blackouts is that the
reason do you see similarities
and i think california is in a tougher
situation because they're
even more reliant upon the green new
deal type of energy such as
wind and solar and they don't have the
capacity that a state like texas does to
be able to tap into fossil fuel and
that's my point sean and that is
if if the body administration is going
to try to eradicate
fossil fuels in the united states every
state
is going to constantly have challenges
like what america has seen take place in
texas right now
it is essential that we as a country
remain where we continue to provide
access
to fossil fuels uh for for heating for
taking care of our homes
for industrial purposes for cities to be
able to run
and so it's just foolish to think that
we can disband the use of fossil fuel
and have a safe and comfortable nation
we're all going to pay more at the pump
we're all going to pay more to heat our
homes
jobs are being lost and these
countries in the middle east some of
which hate our guts they're going to get
rich again
putin is going to benefit financially
the muellers in iran will benefit by
financially and china is going to
benefit
financially so it makes no sense
whatsoever to me to be in the paris
accords where
they look at countries like china and
india as developing nations and we're
paying a hundred times more than they
are
or a significant amount more my question
is right with
so you still have three million people
out of power right now and it's freezing
temperatures
how do you deal with the people that
need help at this time
we provide warming centers across the
entire state of texas
for everybody who's in a situation where
they cannot be warm
in any large city at a minimum there
will be dozens and sometimes
maybe approaching 100 warming centers to
help the people in our state and so we
have the national guard deployed across
the state as well as the texas
department of public safety
the texas transportation division even
texas parks and wildlife
working with local officials to make
sure that our fellow texans they will
they will be taken care of during this
trying time
but our same goal at the same time is to
make sure that we have ercot
working around the clock as well as
working with
the energy generators to make sure they
get the energy
back online so people can back in their
homes and get back to normal as quickly
as possible
i'm watching we just ran some video of
of
plows and i'm thinking texas doesn't
need plows and sanders and salters
uh were you able to work with other
governors how were you able to get those
plows there so fast
sean those were already in texas so the
texas
transportation department they deployed
more than
700 snow plows across the entire state
and there wasn't snow
in your state it doesn't snow that often
there
sean amarillo is closer to colorado than
it is austin texas
and so there are parts of texas where it
actually does
snow that much and so we we were
prepared for that
one thing sean that was uh un
unprecedented uh was the ultra low
below 10 degrees temperature shown by
equivalence
this would be like a week long in alaska
at 100 degrees plus without any air
conditioning which they don't have
because they don't need
and so this is a very
tough week for texans but we're going to
get through it this is going to be
about 60 degrees in austin texas this
weekend and so
the the snow will melt uh the ground
will thaw
and we will work to get back to normal
as quickly as possible all right
one thing i do know about texans they're
tough governor we wish you
the best we we hope you can get your
power up soon so everyone can get back
in their home safely thank you sir